yeah the culture media and Sport
Department essentially says because the
BBC is a public service
um broadcaster because it takes public
funds in the form of the license fee
then clearly they um want to be
essentially kept in the loop with what
is going on um with this apparent
investigation into the unnamed BBC
presenter issuing a statement in the
last 10 minutes or so in which a
spokesperson for the Department said the
allegations were deeply concerning and
that as the BBC is in receipt of Public
Funding senior officials have stressed
to the BBC that the allegations must be
investigated urgent and urgently and
sensitively with the Department kept
informed and that the culture secretary
will be speaking to Tim Davey the Direct
General of the BBC
um later today so it's always a
balancing act for governments and
ministers I think in situations like
this because really of the overall
relationship that the BBC has in terms
of getting its Charter through the
government but being independent of
government so that they're the
government clearly feels that there is a
degree of responsibility to be making
sure that investigations into such
serious allegations are happening
swiftly
um and promptly especially as the family
of the person involved in this when they
spoke to the son clearly had concerns
about the pace at which the BBC was
following up on these complaints and how
seriously they were being taken and I
think listening to both Victoria Atkins
the treasury Minister the government
representative speaking to broadcasters
this morning and also to Rachel Reeves
clearly both of them whilst not
criticizing the BBC both clearly making
the point that they felt that there
would have to be a Swift and prompt
investigation into allegations that are
as serious as this so clearly a feeling
at cabinet level in government that
there needs to be some sort of
involvement if only to establish what
the full facts are around whether a
formal inquiry is now taking place and
that that is why Lucy Fraser the culture
secretary will be meeting with Tim Davey
the BBC director General later today for
Urgent talks about this